audible test driver line hold Eisenhower
says there's a good reason why Audi has
come out with its first-ever compact
sedan worldwide it's the market segment
in greatest demand buyers in the US and
China are especially fond of sloped
rears Germans have a different taste and
we're going to show you whether you'll
learn to like it too it's no coincidence
that Audi is presenting its new sedan in
Budapest it's where the model is being
built its frame option number three in
the new a 3 series after three door and
hatchback to give the family car a
sporty look the engineers have stuck
with a lightweight construction with the
smallest engine possible the four-door
model only weighs 1000 250 kilograms
it's plain to see that the compact sedan
is part of the a3 series with the rear
clearly the distinguishing feature and
focus of attention but otherwise the
only other commonalities of headlights
grille and side mirrors everything else
on the outside has been specially
designed howdy designer Danny grant says
an extra edge has been added to the hood
to give it a more harmonious look the
bumpers have a dual wing elemental it's
custom design for the sedan and the
fenders are also specially crafted for
dealing with Xena the wheel arch is a
little wider for 19-inch rims undercut
edge that makes for a nut shadow I know
one fish mythic under here there's
brings ershon shadow basically portions
for the cars frame are completely
different a chrome rim has been added to
the door to make sure the car is more
leveled and sport here here you see the
design coming through with a shadow that
starts narrow and widens the further
back you go it's a feature that's unique
to this model bit selfish for dealing
with Xena
pointed daylight running lamps are a
common feature of the a3 series and a
linear look also characterizes the
taillights this sought after not after
colita test drive irvine hood says the
trunk has a volume of 880 litres when
the back seats are flipped over even
when they're left in place the trunk
still has 45 to 60 litres more space
than the hatchback or three door Dodge
the wheels are the same distance apart
the sedan is 15 centimeters longer both
the rear passengers and the trunk
benefit from the extra length then for
possession on timki pick up tyler water
in terms of technology the a3 sedan
offers plenty of improvements the a3
sedan is the first car to utilize LTE
the mobile phone standard that's 10
times faster than UMTS it may be a
compact but the cars features our top
class the navigation system can find
available parking spaces on its own and
it can also show the cheaper spots to
fill up the a3 can read your emails
aloud and you can dictate text messages
another comfort feature is that you can
enter your destination in your own
handwriting on the touch pad without
ever having to take your eyes off the
street and liquid assets of them one
nice aspect is that inspire all the
technology the sedan makes do without
too many buttons and switches that makes
it easier to keep an overview
now to the motor and Audi offers to gas
engine options and a diesel
we've tested the stronger gas engine
capable of 132 kilowatts
it gets its strength from 1.8 liters
displacement and can reach a maximum
engine torque of 250 Newton meters that
means acceleration from 0 to 100
kilometres an hour in 7.3 seconds
like the other a 3 models the compact
sedan offers the option of progressive
steering which makes taking the curves
both safer and smoother very line rd
test drive irvine host dies and offices
anyone riding in the a3 sedan could be
mistaken for thinking they're in the a4
or a6 class because the a3 combines Top
Model luxury with Top Model feel and
technology but a competitive compact
price so maybe the Germans will in fact
known to love it
even sportier s3 version with all-wheel
drive and 221 kilowatts of power is also
June to be launched soon
it has ordered in being today sashes
testing the BMW z4 sdrive this models
equipped with the sdrive35is which means
those got a sports transmission and a
250 kilowatt engine buyers have to put a
lot of money into the car it costs just
under seventy thousand euros so the fun
doesn't come cheap the z4 has been
around since 2002 it's in direct
competition with the Audi TT and the
Mercedes SLK but both of those cars have
higher sales figures than the BMW the
price could be a factor in that
grabbin hi santosh sasha says that on
hot days having a convertible is great
especially the zed for because you can
open it while driving up to speeds of 40
kilometres per hour foot sitcom half
when it's powerful engine the roadster
can go from nought to 100 km/h in 4.8
seconds fuel consumption is listed at a
very optimistic 9 liters for 100
kilometers that's probably not the case
in practice
from one look the Zed falls body is BMW
heritage is obvious the front of the car
is classic BMW the headlights are
stocked with xenon bulbs under the hood
a mighty 250 kilowatt engine rumbles
away producing up to 450 newton meters
of torque
because recently had a play slit the
noon version is longer flattered and
sporty-er just a few changes had a big
effect between the LED lights on the
rear the car's trunk doesn't hold much
anyone transporting a lot of luggage
should look elsewhere lucuma scandic
sasha says naturally the car can't have
a big trunk that's how it is there's 380
litres of space but if you bring the
cover down where the top falls in that
goes down to 180 which is practically
nothing did that you push dozens
practice nice
the inside looks good as it should on
any BMW in the center is a fold-out
monitor it controls the BMW
connecteddrive system which allows the
driver to use the internet among other
things the important controls are all on
the central console close to the
automatic gear shift and it features
leather seats
you might struggle to fit a shopping bag
ins and four but who cares when it
handles like a dream and has such an
enormous engine however one drawback is
that the cars emissions make it a bad
choice of the ecologically minded main
facets also what does sasha think of the
BMW z4 he's driven the 35 is model with
a 250 kilowatt engine in theory it's
supposed to use 9 liters of fuel every
100 kilometers but Sasha thinks that's
probably a low estimate that's why if
its efficiency rating is f Mandinka
given that efficiency ratings go from A
plus through a b c d e f and g that
means this car has the second worst
efficiency rating 4 lits if it sends
closer so it's not a car that you should
drive around the block too often ones or
mid-sized money on wink I'd Sophie 50
gigging far
Mercedes have unveiled their new s-class
the new range sets the standard in
technology in comfort it includes both
long and short wheelbase models the cars
come with diesel or two different petrol
engines with the more powerful versions
producing 335 kilowatts of power a
hybrid model is also available a basic
diesel model will set german buyers back
almost eighty thousand euros with a
touch of the screen the cars on its way
volvo has shown off its new assistance
system at the store a home test track in
Sweden started by an app on a smartphone
the system enables the car to park
itself after finding a spare parking
spot fine zone and if anyone walks in
front of the vehicle it pumps the brakes
the system takes the load off for
day-to-day driving and makes the road as
safer place but for now it's still
uncertain when the system and vehicles
will go on sale
this is the dream of every classic car
fanatic an underground garage chock full
of vintage automobiles and the best part
is every single ones for sale the garage
functions as a showroom for these
beauties gents zel cashed fulfilled a
lifelong ambition when he opened the
shop shop tomorrow tomorrow he says he's
always had antique cars and driven them
in tours and rallies he bought and sold
cars like it was a card game mostly
Italian cars he says when he moved to
Hamburg he decided that instead of
taking his cast with dealer we could do
it himself milder some Copic fund
admitted after I trust the odds went
ahead and clean Kyle's there are they
said the handler yen's has a huge array
of classic cars available at reasonable
prices most of them from the 60s and 70s
body has some newer models to
if this renault r15 isn't you'll think
there'll be another full wheel gem
around the corner tempting you to part
with your money Felicia Gannon them
classifies gentle eyes to operate at
prices of up to thirty thousand euros
and sometimes even under 10,000 that
said creme de tends to buy well captain
too much restoration phone gents is
trying to find a buyer for this TVR it's
got something special under the hood
it's a 5-liter v8 engine from a Ford
Mustang which could push out 300
horsepower we want to see it in action
so current owner Carl Turner takes it
for a spin
TV are released the m-series in 1972
first for the 2.5 liter 6-cylinder
engine made my triumph later that was
replaced by a 3-liter v6 Ford engine for
the 3000m model
are you mr. positive is a tester forward
to Mitzi asks Carl why he put an even
bigger engine into the car star some
amount of Carl says he'd always dreamed
of having a 3000m perhaps with a Ford v8
motor so when he had to restore the
engine he decided to put in the eighth
cylinder motor was kind of applies to
him after the normal time yeah
let expire smart TV are also later
released a factory-made 8 cylinder model
but only 20 were produced they served as
cars inspiration for this souped-up
version of the TVR 3000
the long flat grill and the short rear
end our typical to be our traits and
like all of their cars it's built with a
fiberglass chassis
in a car like this a woman wants to put
his foot down but as it's up for sale
he's taking it easy for something bigger
for those moments driven many cars but
this has a light frame and a fat v8 at
the front with 300 horsepower so he says
it deserves respect respect sir
FSS a woman says the car handles
surprisingly well around the bends he
doesn't feel like it's over powered or
unsteady thinks the car runs very well
considering its 35 years on static
feraldo that's the lot of asiago just
until it was split up in 2006 TVR was a
small but successful sports car maker
based in Blackpool England
as the old woman thinks it's terrible
that TVR isn't making cars anymore he
says the company was taken over by some
rich Russian kick or Victor smolinski
quickly killed guitars was born in
school Naaman on terra firma billion
curse that I day in the Earth orbits
counted out all his pennies and
unfortunately he can't afford the TVR
5000m but for someone with a bulging
wallets there's a great little car
sitting in jens's underground garage in
Hamburg
it's the 10th annual VW bus get together
in San power pescador near Spain's Costa
Brava and here you can see old and new
VW buses high and low VW buses colourful
and black and white buses there are rare
and not so rare specimens somewhere high
tops and pop tops some made of rust and
son of canvas test driver Matta scott is
in his element some of these buses have
come a long way to be here today matters
came down to Spain from Germany through
France with a group of VW bus fans uber
fan cake Nash Banyon that was a distance
of nearly 1400 kilometers mostly on
country roads there are VW buses from
the 1980s 90s and current models but the
star of the show our VW California
camper buses which turned 25 this year
VW buses are notoriously sluggish even
the turbocharged 1.6 litre diesel in the
t3 series only manages 51 kilowatts of
power and a maximum speed of 127
kilometres per hour drivers of the newer
buses here agreed to keep to this limit
as a gesture of solidarity
this time the rain in Spain fell mainly
in the mountains but only for about half
an hour and not enough to block the
spectacular view
volkswagen has been building campers
since the 1950s but it's become
increasingly expensive and complicated
to outfit them so the West failures
interior was simplified and VW tossed
out many of the extras to create the
California
after nearly three days on the road our
group was getting close we crossed the
eastern pyrenees and headed south toward
the Mediterranean
past abandoned customs houses across the
border to Spain
since it first came out in 1988 the
California has remained much the same
the first generation based on vw's t3
bus made a hit with its versatility it
was a practical workers and much more
even with the built-in kitchen it's
still slept up to four people
in the 1990s VW introduced different
versions of the tea for California it
even included a built-in toilet the
first VW camper to have one the
interior's versatility and ease of use
have remained unchanged
you
the current generation of the VW Bus t5
has been on the road since 2003 a few
useful gadgets have been added to the
California's camping features such as
the folding chairs stowed inside the
tailgate there's lots more storage a
mini kitchen and still room to sleep for
people comfortably
inadequate edvard a test driver matter
skillet assumes the VW t5 would
outclassed the other buses in almost any
category it's fast and powerful it's
safer more comfortable and takes less
fuel skip is one category where he says
the VW 23 California wins hands down and
that's the cult factor it'll take some
time before even the t4 achieves that
cult status the last of the rear drive
t3 VW buses were long something of a
laughing stock but now they too have
their hardcore of devoted fans